à la france le pays de la gastronomie
avec ses saveurs ses produits ses vignes
et surtout son savoir faire culinaire
qui a vu émerger les plus grands chefs
étoilés
on imagine que les habitants de ce
terroir du goût doivent être à la
hauteur de cette réputation mondiale en
étant de vrais cordon bleu al dente
alors je sais pas vous mais moi quand il
s'agit de cuisiner pas cuisiner c'est un
grand mot ils ont plutôt faire à manger
rien ne marche pas je fais cuire un truc
il ya tellement de fumée qu'on voit plus
les meubles quand je fais des poissons
panés la panure elle reste sur la poêle
ça fait des poissons panés décapoté
quand je conserve de la nourriture au
frigo au bout d'une semaine j'ai créé
une nouvelle forme de vie
quand je fais cuire un truc j'ai
l'impression qu'elle est a pas cuit puis
l'étape brûler quand je fais une pizza
au four elle traverse les barreaux quand
je casser un oeuf je passe ma vie à
enlever les coquilles quand je fais un
truc surgelés au micro ondes
c'est brûlant à l'extérieur et glacée à
l'intérieur utilisez une poêle égale
écrive une poêle
et quand je fais bouillir de l'eau en
général je pars tellement longtemps que
quand je reviens bahia plus tôt il fait
un peu humide isséens c'est quoi ça même
où moi je sais pas faire à manger
1 c'est pas dans mes gènes après qu'on
ait des invités a quand même un truc que
je connaisse et ces délits 0 everitt
après déjà faut faire la différence
entre quand tu fais à manger pour
plusieurs personnes et quand tu fais à
manger juste pour toi tu vas prenons un
truc simple genre qu à des trucs à la
poêle à quand tu fais ça et des petite
giclée d'huile brûlante qui te sautent
dessus
du coup tu es comme un conte à essayer
des petites techniques la technique du
bras le plus long possible utiliser un
objet extérieur se protéger comme on
veut ou carrément la technique persona
éteindre le feu retourner la viande et
rallume je pense que je suis trop
impatient pour cuisiner parce que dès
qu'il faut attendre un peu que sa cuisse
je me casse faire une autre activité
ensemble chez de retour à temps pour la
cuisson
bon là ça cuit ça va durer environ d'une
minute
ces petits l'été culte au québec on
enchaîne fait du jeu est trop bien fait
là il ya une mise à jour où il ya
certains aliments je n'ai même pas
essayé de les faire ce que tu as beau
attirer chez toi après tes vêtements est
ta maison sont imprégnés de l'odeur what
what a cuisiné des sardines je me trompe
ouais ouais c'est vrai mais c'était en
janvier il ya deux mois c'est dur de
respecter des recettes parce que ce soit
j'ai jamais les ingrédients qu'il faut
ou souvent je me sens plus et j'en
rajoute comme si ça allait rien changer
au maire dit que deux mois et ça passe
fo du lait bon j'en ai pas c'est bon
c'est pas indispensable la levure
on s'en bat les couilles et le gâteau au
chocolat
qu'en faire à manger à plusieurs en
famille ou autre je déteste ce mec qui
coûte le plein directement dans la
casserole attend juste avant de servir
[Musique]
là tu veux tu peux te savais ni ce mec
qui se vend tout le temps d'être bon
vivant généreux en matière grasse et
vas-y je suivais des trucs on lésine pas
sur lui il le fut qu on y va évidemment
le beurre à je te mets le doigt et robin
un os et puis reçu qu encore un peu on
appuie un peu nul encore on est gourmand
il est comme ça il faut savoir manger tu
laisses un peu mijoter à feu doux et on
obtient
une ordonnance pour un séjour à
l'hôpital
ou alors cette personne qui a cuisiné
c'est très sympa nick est totalement au
taquet de savoir si son plat te plaît ou
pas alors maintenant j'ai pas encore
goûté là
c'est bon bagage écoute là là je montre
alors oui c'est bon c'est super bon
c'est délicieux baptême pas goûté là
j'avoue que dès qu'il faut cuisiner à
plusieurs et j'en ai pleuré flemme j'ai
encore une petite technique c'est que je
propose mon aide mais à la toute fin
comme ça je fais le moins possible
voulez vous aidera à ba on a fini non
mais si vous êtes vite fais pas de souci
bon on préfère qu'on a fait ensemble à
sa part une équipe bon appétit ne dit
pas merci c'est trop fort parfois des
amis me demandent de leur faire un plat
typique de ma région natale
c'est à dire le nord de la france enfin
les eaux de france jeunes or quoi mais
dans le nord n'y a pas trente six mille
pas non plus j'ai pas les faire du coup
ce que je peux leur proposer c'est
éventuellement la cuisine du nord alors
dial qu'est ce que vous allez proposer
aujourd'hui j'étais veut faire des le
fruit de leurs calculs de ch'nord tpr en
effet deux comme show des ménages corner
je suis tout à fait au niveau du plat
vaches et où la cuisine de ch'nord
d'ailleurs les émissions de cuisine je
trouve ça hyper frustrant c'est ça leur
ultra bon avec de magnifiques gros plan
il te regarde sans rejoint un vieux
trucs merdiques
ces émissions de cuisine j'ai
l'impression qu'au fil des années elles
ont un peu influencer les gens des fois
les gens qui ont été invités chez eux et
je crois dans un dîner presque parfait
ils se prennent beaucoup trop la tête
hop hop hop hop hop hop avant vous
négociez je m'explique quand même voilà
je vous ai fait un chutney de mangue
braisé revenu sur son coulis de coco
sauvage que j'ai fait revenir quelques
minutes à feu doux dans un bain marie à
l'arménienne voilà après je me suis un
petit peu plaisir moi j'ai plus fin au
fait si vous avez des restes ne sais pas
quoi en faire
baho de les acheter et de gaspiller il
existe plein de l'application anti
gaspillage alimentaire pensez-y c'est
pratique et écolo bon voila moi je sais
pas faire à manger
je sais juste m'alimenter et c'est déjà
très bien on va pas se plaindre en tout
cas quand je regarde des vidéos de
cuisine sur internet je me rends compte
que je suis pas le seul au monde à pas
savoir cuisiner et ça ça me rassure
coeur et où j'ai pas comment conclure
allez
[Musique]